how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to the channel and it's
been a while but we have some venom 2
news and today we have some real plot
details meaning that the information of
where this is coming from has been
confirmed to be true
and although this plot leaked doesn't
talk about the entirety and everything
that is going to be taking place during
venom 2 it does talk a lot about Cletus
Kasady who of course goes on to be
carnage and it also talks about shriek
who we know to be carnage is love
interest
so this leak doesn't spoil the entire
movie but it does spoil some parts of it
so if you're trying to avoid any and all
spoilers for venom 2 you should probably
click away now we're gonna talk about
this plot leak and talk about how venom
could possibly tie into Morbius and how
they could be setting up the sinister
six I'll break it all down in this video
but first if you knew be sure to
subscribe to stay up to date on
everything relating to the venom verse
and of course the MCU and real quick
announcement on my side channel cosmic
culture that I have with my buddy Chris
were given away a Captain America shield
on February 1st just a couple of days
away to enter just go over to the
channel and subscribe and comment on our
videos on that channel of course we talk
about Marvel but we talk about all
movies in general
so today's plot leak comes from HN
Entertainment and they have learned some
details about carnage and shriek in the
upcoming venom sequel currently filming
at Warner Brothers Studios Leavesden in
Watford England and HN Entertainment
were actually the first to announced
that venom 2 would be filming at that
studio and they state that Cletus Kasady
who of course is going to be played by
Woody Harrelson and of course is going
to get the carnage symbiote is set to be
executed by the state of California for
multiple murders Cletus Kasady was in
the Ravencroft Institute for the
criminally insane but he manages to
escape alongside Frances Louise Barisan
aka shriek and right now shriek is
confirmed to be in venom 2 reportedly
played by Naomi Harris although I don't
think that's confirmed yet but Frances
Louise Barisan aka shriek is expected to
be a fellow inmate at Ravencroft meaning
that she just doesn't show up and break
him out all of a sudden she was in there
with him the entire time they say
whether or not Cletus Kasady already has
the carnage symbiote at this point in
the film remains to be seen but it
sounds like he hasn't transformed into
the film's big bad just yet and that
makes sense because if he did in
fact have the carnage symbiote already
he definitely wouldn't need help escape
in the facility so when he's in the
facility at this point in time he most
likely doesn't have the carnage symbiote
but HN Entertainment goes on to say that
cletus's violent past as a child will
also be explored in the film after Tom
Hardy posted a photo of the remains of
an orphanage that Cletus burns down as a
child and this orphanage is the st.
astaizzu boys we learned that this is
why Eddie Brock is at the orphanage and
after some investigative reporting we
find out that the 12 deaths from the
fire will be uncovered as being the
direct result of cletus's actions and
adding to his already hefty body count
now what most likely happens here is
that after interviewing Cletus Kasady
Eddie Brock is given some information
and goes to investigate the fire Eddie
Brock is the one that exposes the new
victims adding to the murders that
Cletus Kasady has committed and then his
career as a journalist gets a massive
boost and could potentially place a
target on his back from the newly
escaped Cletus Kasady now these plot
points that were veiled about Cletus
Kasady escaping with the help of shriek
are good news and the reason is is
because it seems like they're sticking
true to the comics especially the
maximum carnage crossover because what
happened in that crossover which is
where shriek debuted for the very first
time in Marvel Comics is that carnage
actually breaks out himself in a very
very violent way he then finds shriek
who was also incarcerated and he helps
her escape shriek chooses to join
carnage and the two of them embark on a
massive killing spree now again the fact
that shriek has to help Cletus Kasady
escape the Institute means that he
probably doesn't have the symbiote at
this point in time but if they're
sticking close to what carnage is like
in the comics which hopefully they do
that means we're going to get a very
violent carnage which is what everybody
wants and it kind of seems like they're
setting him up this way Cletus Kasady is
incarcerated as we saw at the end and
the post-credits scene of venom 2 and
apparently is going to be executed
because of the murders that he is
committed now this also happens in the
comics but right when he's about to be
executed the carnage symbiote attaches
to him and helps him escape so perhaps
we'll see somewhat of a similar
situation here but hopefully they'll do
as much as they can with a pg-13 rated
carnage and I know a lot of people would
really like venom 2 to be rated R but
here's
a good reason why it should be pg-13 and
that is so eventually venom can go on to
join the sinister six I know most of you
caught the Morbius trailer and you
caught the one scene where Spiderman was
on the wall and over his picture it said
murderer now venom and Morbius are
supposed to exist in the same universe
and it has already been confirmed that
Sony has been talking with Tom Holland
about making a spider-man cameo in venom
2 so therefore it does make sense that
Morbius and venom exist in the same
universe and of course we can't forget
about Michael Keaton's cameo in the
Morbius trailer as well as vulture now
there's been a bit of debate on whether
or not this is actually the same vulture
from the Marvel Cinematic Universe but
the general consensus is that it is and
according to Mikey Sutton who broke
details about the Sony Marvel Disney
deal when all of the mess with
spider-man staying in the MCU was going
on he says that this is in fact Adrian
Toomes from the MCU apparently the new
deal between Sony and Disney / Marvel is
that spider-man can exist in the Sony
spider-verse and that would include
venom carnage Morbius Kraven the hunter
and more that they have come in as well
however Sony is only going to be able to
reference Sony owned characters that
exist in the MCU which is why we can see
vulture in the Morbius trailer so
everything that happened in spider-man
far from home technically happened in
the Sony spider-man universe which
includes Morbius and venom and if we
think about everything that executive
producer Amy Pascal said she said that
we have currently all the villains we
need to make up the sinister six and
right now we do we have vulture
chameleon scorpion Mysterio because I
think a lot of people think that he's
actually alive Morbius and now venom
it's not the traditional sinister six
but a sinister six nonetheless and with
the inclusion of spider-man from the MCU
in the Morbius trailer that pretty much
confirms that they're all connecting and
based off of what we've seen and what
everybody is saying the sinister six are
only a matter of time and of course you
have to remember that the Sony Disney /
Marvel deal was for a solo film and then
a crossover film the crossover film
could be the sinister six and the
founder of the sinister six could be
Norman Osborn unfortunately that is just
speculation for now we'll
have to wait and see if norman osborn is
going to make his appearance in the MCU
or at the Sony verse but regardless it
does seem like the sinister six is right
around the corner so let me know what
you think about these new details about
venom 2 and let me know what you would
think about this group of the sinister
six let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to give
the video a like and subscribe when
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to
venom 2 spider-man and the MCU and of
course so you can enter my giveaway for
a chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 I'm
picking a winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof